i want to pull up the story though
because we're talking about republicans
we got this reporting from michael tracy
over at his uh m tracy sub stack he says
media promotes fake vaccine hesitancy
narrative to justify coercion and
scolding this is an excellent bit of
reporting because michael tracy
basically went through this the the
republicans what their statements have
been on vaccines and he is outright
definitively proved proving the media is
lying yeah when what but it's you know
what's insane to me how is it there are
so many like left personalities and
democrats who genuinely believe
conservatives opposed vaccines right i'm
really confused he's got donald trump he
says this one produces an overload of
cognitive dissonance both among hardcore
trump supporters and detractors the
simple fact is that trump presided over
and spearheaded operation warp speed the
federal government's initiative to
publicly fund the production and
manufacture of a vaccine on an expedited
time scale far beyond anything ever
before attempted in history whether or
not trump should receive credit for
doing this as an ancillary pundit style
consideration it's just the factual
reality of course throughout 2020 trump
was pilloried by self-appointed
fact-checkers the most exalted guardians
of the facts for his assurances that a
vaccine would be available on an
expedited schedule but then that's
exactly what happened put another way
if there's any single individual who's
most directly responsible for the
historically unprecedented mass
provision of vaccines perhaps other than
the scientists who actually created them
that individual would have to be donald
trump
this isn't something that's often
acknowledged by most of the hardcore
online factions of trump supporters who
tend to lean vaccine skeptical nor is it
acknowledged by trump's opponents who
shudder at the mere thought of assigning
him credit for anything but it's also
just true i think didn't biden say the
vaccine was created under the republican
administration and he praised mcconnell
for promoting the vaccine
maybe you know it's really funny
democrats are sitting there like why
won't people get the vaccines and
they're like maybe we should just like
let them know that donald trump's the
one who did it and give credit to the
republicans
really and then biden's like oh actually
i mean credit goes to them
here's what he says
he goes on trump himself seems cognizant
of this at every opportunity he trumpets
operation warp speed as one of his
administration's signature
accomplishments and understandably so
yeah
so uh tracy notes that uh trump urges
all americans to get coveted vaccine
it's a safe vaccine and it works the
former president and first lady melania
trump received their vaccines privately
in january at the white house mike pence
pro-vaccine the whole time
ron desantis he said here's another odd
one when the vaccines first became
available the santas immediately
declared quote we are working to get as
much vaccine for our citizens as
possible and implemented a distribution
plan that prioritized elderly florida
residents which resulted in a bizarre
round of media pushback as though
prioritizing the elderly for vaccine
distribution was some sinister vlog
desantis also personally received the
vaccine and publicized this fact when
his age group first became eligible like
all other republican governors he's been
in charge of administering and promoting
his state's vaccination program from the
outset and one of the reasons they
lifted the lockdowns was they're like
we're good vaccines roll them out i was
living in florida when the vaccines were
rolled out i got my vaccine in florida
desantis was all over the place touting
vaccines the idea that he was against
vaccines is like comical it's like he
both like got the vaccines to too
quickly to his people and you also
didn't want them to take it like how
could it be both it's this is the
weirdest thing so we then i'll just i'll
just show you the other name the other
names we've got greg abbott always in
favor christie gnome uh mitch mcconnell
ted cruz marco rubio kevin mccarthy tom
cotton josh hawley they have all been
been been been pushing this
yet somehow the narrative is all of a
sudden republicans are coming around
right this is insane you even had the
what was it it was k ivy where she was
like the spread is the fault of the
unvaccinated i'm like literally
everybody like in politics is
pro-vaccine yeah
that
the media for some reason created this
narrative
why
i mean i think because they want to
blame somebody and they can't blame
their own factions who aren't taking the
vaccine i mean black and hispanic
americans are among the lowest
percentages of vaccinated americans and
so
they can't criticize them and so they
find the trump you know the trump lovers
and blame it on them
what's fascinating to me is that you now
have the two most popular
conservative or right-wing candidates
donald trump and ron desantis in in in
the cpac poll trump dominates they took
trump out ron desantis dominates
trump is begging for the credit on the
vaccine he's like sending out these
emails i get him and he's like i did all
this and like our administration and the
democrats won't admit it and ron
desantis himself led the charge and the
media is trying to claim conservatives
are anti-vaxx you know what the issue is
there was one study i saw
well briefly a lot of people noted this
or were sharing the study it found that
vaccine hesitant individuals that they
called anti-vaxxers were more
knowledgeable about the data of the
science and what was currently going on
i think the simple answer is that when
people do the research
when they take a look at their medical
histories and then go talk to their
doctors
they tend to make private and personal
medical decisions for the betterment of
their lives and it's not the result
often that the democrats want to see
happen
i mean they could also solve the does
donald trump want people to take the
vaccine by having any number of
reporters who still speak to him on a
semi-regular basis ask him do you want
people to take the vaccine i think that
would just you know get to the bottom of
it pretty quickly but they don't want to
hear the answer to that because they
know he's going to say yes they know
he's going to say yeah of course i want
you to take the trump vaccine the
greatest vaccine that's ever been
produced
did the vaccine with my in the backyard
yeah
trump is uh i don't know if uh for those
that are listening if you saw the
freedom tunes uh clip we just put out
where it's uh uh fauci and trump are in
mount doom in the woohon wet market and
vouchers like cast it into the fire but
then trump is basically a hearing saying
i am the greatest president who has ever
lived even fauci agrees in fact she's
like no i don't
but that's that's you know the reason
that joke works is because donald trump
if they gave him a prescott if they
wanted give the man a press conference
bring him out to the front the rose
garden one more time come on in trump
here's the microphone what do you guys
say about that it was me it was all me i
did all the work everybody should be
supporting this
i mean it's true yeah it's is he saying
everyone should get the vaccine yeah
well i mean i just write this quote
that's a dangerous rhetoric people need
to talk about i agree i agree and also
for him to say that it's the most
effective vaccine or incred is is
unknown yet but it's trumpy you know
like trump would just be like this is
the best vaccine ever because i wasn't
is he responsible for this becoming
politicized in the first place
the way he talks about it i mean i
wouldn't call him responsible i'd say
the media is responsible like he should
have come out something like i have a i
have accrued a huge group of doctors to
look at this and they're all going to
take over i have a giant panel of 60
doctors from around the world that are
going to control this from here on out
there are a lot of things trump could
have done that he didn't do instead he's
like i'm gonna do it it's my put my name
on that thing it's like obamacare man
you ruined health care by politicizing
who was it who came out and said they
should call it the trump vaccine was
that geraldo or i don't know if those
are all somewhat uh
somebody it was a really good idea yeah
called the trump vaccine but but i'm
like why the democrats wouldn't take it
it would have the same problem yeah uh
yes yes so the fox news story march 16th
trump urges all americans to get coveted
vaccine it's a safe vaccine and it works
there's no no evidence for that he's
still finding out as we go here's the
issue i i have and like i am always
criticizing the media that that is that
is the main issue
when you have 336 million doses or
whatever because we're doing a massive
rollout across the country then you're
going to end up with a disproportionate
amount of news stories about adverse
reactions
i take those stories seriously and i
want to make sure that i i will never
give someone advice and then the last
thing i want is for someone to show up
with a crutch being like you said do
this
that's why i'm like you got to make
these decisions for yourself and that's
why it's dangerous to just like make
these demands but i do think one of the
reasons we have so many reports in the
vera system the vaccine adverse event
reporting system is simply the number of
vaccines that have been administered
i i think you know it's it's in the
media it's talked about a whole lot so
people are more cognizant of what's
going on and
everybody's going to get it plus like i
said before some people aren't talking
to their doctors so they're they that
may be a good portion of the adverse
events but it's just it's a personal
decision you got to make for yourself
and you know outside of
all that i do think there's a problem
with
there was a wall street journal op-ed i
can't i can't tell you about we can talk
about it in the bonus segment but
youtube's got specific rules
uh that was questioning the fda and
their decisions and so i'll just put it
that way that there are mainstream news
articles saying we aren't doing right by
people based on you know
how to respond to this pandemic which is
we'll have to save it because we'll get
banned if i get into it no joke it's a
wall street journal article but yeah
youtube's rules are so
bonkers
that simply citing it is a bandworthy
offense that's that's that's that's the
state of this country and i think that's
a really good reason as to why
information overload everything's mixed
up and broken and we can't figure out
what's going on yeah
hard to trust really hard to trust right
now
i don't think i keep saying that this is
the worst pr campaign they ever ran like
how are you supposed to convince people
to take any kind of universal medicine
if you keep going back and forth at
every level every single person rachelle
willenski dr fauci these are the people
that we look up to rachelle wolenski
said earlier i think it was today she
was talking about the kids who have died
of cobot she literally said things that
are factually provable with the cdc's
data untrue completely untrue did you
know what you said she was talking about
how it's like more dangerous than the
flu for kids and people yeah it's just
this is clearly not true well i'm i i
don't know i don't know about that uh i
do know that when crowder said cite the
cdc data he got he got banned from
youtube for it well well or he he got a
suspension for bringing it up so i don't
know i'll just say uh you know whatever
whatever willenski says whatever fauci
says it's true it's all true it's all
true yeah even if they say something
different tomorrow yeah well that's just
sorry
so that was a really good point brought
up in um
where was this point brought up i'm
forgetting that oh yeah it was it was uh
uh was it peter ducey or steve which
one's which one's the younger one peter
peter yeah he asked uh jen sackey about
the censorship and he said there's a
video from march about you saying not to
wear a mask that's still up and you know
you know people see that he's like
aren't you concerned that you might get
something removed that later turns out
to be true for him yeah yeah she's not
concerned
well
but this is it's the best example i
think this last year is the best example
of the problem with censorship
and centralized control of
communications doesn't work because
that's right fauci
has been wrong on numerous occasions and
his response is but it's the science
okay i can respect that the science
changed
the problem is
you banned people
for what is now
the right response right you know like
you later come back and say oh those
people write the whole time then why'd
you ban them
that's where we're currently at yeah i
mean you're right that it this year was
a a big test case for censorship but i
don't see people being outraged about it
i feel like just americans have been so
muted about this kind of thing it's it's
really disappointing
yeah it should be across the board
outrage it shouldn't just be people on
the right
i don't know how we're going to solve
whatever is going on you got to build a
new tech the media has just shattered
yeah that's why we're working on the
fetiverse and expanding fetiverse
projects because you i don't think you
can you can legislate a solution to tech
oligarchs yeah censoring the world so
we're trying to build a decentralized
network that's uncensorable essentially
yeah and i don't think that improving
the technology is going to make people
want to be more honest like the problem
that we're looking at is kind of like a
human problem this is a question i have
but i have about a lot of ais who
programs the ai that determines what
goes on if it's humans you're going to
literally have the exact same problem
you have with humans but at least ai so
it'll be different special it's like it
does it just looks good
look at the self-driving car problem
right so we're trying to program cars to
drive themselves but there are some
really serious questions that we can
answer like if you're driving in a car
and the car drives cars driving itself
and an old lady walks in front of you
does the car decide to hit the old lady
to protect the driver or swerve out of
the way to save the old lighter and res
save the old lady and risk the driver
someone has to tell the car what to do
or i guess the funny thing is we'll be
like we'll give it an ai an artificial
intelligence it'll figure it out on its
own and the car decides to hit everybody
it's like ah whatever get them out of
the road no so somebody's gotta program
those parameters you know maybe maybe
there should be like three rules like
like never harm a human
and um the second rule should be like uh
uh
always follow the instructions of a
human and the third rule is unless it
contradicts the first rule or whatever
what what are the what are the three
rules i'm forgetting them talking about
skynet no what are you talking about i
was like isn't it like asimov's right
don't become sentient oh yeah
no thinking don't destroy us
i like that meme that's like i think you
there's the cop and he's like i think
you've had a [ __ ] too i think you've
had a bit too much to think
and he's like yeah waking his finger at
you and it says thought police or
whatever so here's what's happened right
so i wake up in the morning and i see
these stories and they're like dc's
locking down and nevada's locking down
and i'm like i have no idea what's going
on
i have no idea what the rationale is i
have no rationale i have no idea what
the data is there's no there's no
science anymore yeah there's there's
contradictory studies across the board
saying one thing saying something else
then people are accusing one study of
being political another study being
political and i'm just sitting here like
i wonder what the chickens are up to
right like i can't i can't i can't talk
about it i can't open on it i'm just
like
everybody's gone nuts yeah the machine's
broken
you know it's political madness this is
why i err on the side of like becoming
an artist a famous artist you look at
like rock stars and how well loved they
are like dave grohl
if we had that kind of cultural sway i
mean so much more
effective than complaining about it or
even trying to fix it politically you
can't you can't politically fix this
thing it needs a technology didn't they
do a concert
did they do a concert where you had to
get the vaccine to come in and then one
of the members of the band who's
vaccinated
somebody involved with the organization
they didn't say who amazing probably in
the band i don't know i see stories like
that i'm like i don't know what this
means right if you're vaccinated and
you're putting on events for only
vaccinated people why are you shutting
down because one person was sick i
thought that's what they said was going
to happen
i don't think i got to be honest i don't
think anybody knows right i think
there's a lot of people who want to
think it's a grand conspiracy because we
talk about the great reset quite a bit
and i'm like i don't know i think
they're juggling you know there it's a
bunch of people all juggling and no one
has any idea of who's doing what or why
i think incompetence is usually the best
explanation i think we really have a
bunch of incompetent people who have no
idea what's happening and don't want to
you know give up this moment of power
for themselves and don't want this to
end
right fauci is very famous right now
yeah more than he's on tv all the time
yeah when's that going to happen again
this is it this is well he's been on tv
before yeah he's been intense yeah but
i've never heard of him but this is not
your best you're a young
he's always like 18 80 i think yeah oh
wow yeah so he's been around for quite a
long time tony you look good for an 80
year old that's great right yeah he gets
paid you know more than the president
he's the highest paid federal employee
oh that's so messed up not elected well
look
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you